mayo is always in on it here mayo says
fox news is spawning over kim jong-un
they are a traitor network that is
creating more and more domestic
terrorists
they're actually trying to burn this
country to the ground
yep
and what they're saying about kim
jong-un is only is only
perpetuation of that [ __ ] the same thing
they do with vladimir putin
it's the same [ __ ] because they find uh
these these strong men quote unquote
as uh
as good for politics
uh you guys seen the video of the of the
little boy the other day
on the the little man-child on the beach
accosting a group of women because they
had bikinis on it's that same [ __ ]
it's that same [ __ ] and he actually went
on and maybe i'll play it he went on
tick-tock and he did a oh my side of the
story my side of the story
thing but
yeah
let's see princesses get princess has
got another one here let's go back
to the comments
uh she's saying before i play the videos
here i wanna
she's saying it's a bad body double
princess said it's a bad body double
uh do you guys notice i can now show you
i figured this out i don't know
i don't know why i didn't know this it's
because i'm not you know i'm new at this
i'm i'm a streaming virgin so um
i i can show your
your comments which is kind of cool so
we'll start doing that as you guys come
and i'll try to show and then respond
you guys i don't do that a lot on the
podcast because i'm in the zone but here
it's a lot more casual we're just we're
just surfing
we're surfing
everybody gone surfing
surfing usa
okay uh so let's play this video and
this one here
of uh
you can see here uh he's spotted
in a light suit oh man he's got a tan
look at him waving let's pause it here
bup okay so so this is kim jong-un
supposedly some are saying it's not but
supposedly it's it's him this here this
guy right here in the tan suit
and